hop là regardez venez comment est-ce que
vous allez aujourd'hui est-ce que ça
roule aujourd'hui on se parle de ce
smartphone ce smartphone qui vient tout
juste d'être annoncé hop là je pars mes
vêtements tout va bien qui vient tout
juste d'être annoncé c'est le Xiaomi
c'est le 12 t pro 12T pro que d'être
fait sur un lancement international à
Munich et je crois la première fois que
je suis omi a fait un lancement
international en Europe à midi c'est
très très chouette et alors moi je
voulais vous parler de ce smartphone
pour tout vous dire que ça fait 3
semaines que j'ai dans la poche et je le
trouve intéressant sur un truc qui est
vachement cool et si on vient zoomer il
se peut qu'on le voit c'est ça là on a
un capteur principal enfin il y a plutôt
là mais c'est écrit ici c'est du 200
mégapixels 200 mégapixels déjà l'année
dernière Xiaomi c'est avec le 11 thé ou
le 11 c'était Pro a fait de la recharge
120 watts donc ils augmentaient les
chiffres et là il repose encore plus les
chiffres alors l'idée c'est pas
d'arriver plus tard sur une caméra
400-500 mégapixels quoi que peut-être
allez savoir c'est pas convaincu mais
bon au moins il y a des limites mais là
il y a une repousser davantage de trucs
donc ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui et
bien c'est une vidéo à venir découvrir
sur smartphone on va regarder ce qu'il
fait on va regarder les premières images
et puis surtout si aujourd'hui une vidéo
qui réalisait en collaboration avec
Xiaomi sur mes mamie tiens mon bon
monsieur gros est-ce que ne voudrais pas
présenter notre smartphone il était
évident que j'allais le faire puisqu'on
me propose et bien on va y aller
directement vous êtes prêt vous êtes
prêts on y va
alors je voudrais qu'on regarde
directement ce qui se passe au niveau du
design on retrouve vraiment la pâte
qu'on a sur les smartphones de Xiaomi de
cette année avec ce bloc photo sur le
côté que je trouvais élégant plutôt
sympa ça marche bien le branding la
marque ici Xiaomi on a un truc qui est
sympa alors j'aime bien cette petite
découpe là qu'on va avoir vous voyez
sont tirer des petits traits constants
sous le doigt ça doit être fait au laser
c'est plutôt sympa le 200 mégapixels qui
apparaît là c'est très léger mais on
sait à quel smartphone on a affaire
quand on voit ça smartphone qui est
sympa qui se prend très très bien en
main on fait le tour alors attendez
peut-être faire le tour presque complet
comme ça mais bon le format est plutôt
cool ça smartphone qui fait 205 g donc
c'est pas le plus léger du marché mais
bon voilà vous avez un Corning Aurillac
5 à l'avant qui va venir le protéger
alors il existe dans différentes coloris
ici j'ai le modèle noir mais il existe
également en gris et en modèle bleu le
truc qui va être intéressant c'est qu'on
a un très grand écran regardez un très
grand écran il appelle ça le cristal
rise c'est de la molette vous avez un
écran de
6,67 pouces plutôt bien confortable pour
venir regarder des films des séries on
en reparle plus tard et là c'est
vraiment une première découverte enfin
je vous fais un premier on se finira le
test d'ici quelques jours donc pensez à
vous abonner si c'est pas déjà fait et
si vous êtes abonné pensez également à
actionner la cloche pour être notifié
qu'une prochaine vidéo arrivera et ça
c'est vachement bien on a un combo
gagnant c'est à dire que vous avez un
taux de rafraîchissement sans Hertz
c'est du vert adaptatif ça veut dire
qu'il va venir s'adapter automatiquement
on va passer de 30 60 90 jusqu'à 120 Hz
30 lorsque vous avez pas grand chose qui
va venir s'afficher puis plus vous allez
avoir besoin plus vous allez monter au
nombre d'images par seconde vous avez
également un taux d'échantillonnage
tactile notamment pour le gaming 480
Hertz un écran avec un ratio 20/9 très
longue bien pour le format cinéma pour
venir regarder des films et des séries
résolution Full HD plus 446 pixels par
pouce Dolby vision hdr10 plus bref une
belle dalle bien calibrée et ça marche
bien alors autre point qui est aussi
important à venir connaitre ici vous
avez des haut-parleurs stéréo par leur
stéréo qui sont cool pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont fait un boulot qui est pas
mal vous avez le premier haut-parleur
qui situe là et deuxième haut-parleur
c'est pas celui qu'on va retrouver ici
c'est à dire le haut-parleur pour passer
les coups de filles non c'est le
haut-parleur vous avez ici alors il y a
un truc qui est cool hop là on va couper
c'est qu'il y a un et tais-toi monsieur
gros c'est qu'il y a un côté image
stéréoscopique c'est à dire que le son
sort de là et le son sort de là il sort
pas en façade là donc on est à côté plus
immersif et ça c'est vraiment bien au
niveau de l'expérience audio pour autant
ici on aura en haut parleur qui
délivrera un peu moins d'aigu donc un
peu plus grave on sent lorsqu'on écoute
comme ça par contre je trouve cool c'est
quand ce que vous le connais comme ça ça
vous envoie plus de son dans la tronche
ça c'est plutôt cool donc ça c'est bien
qu'on est ici haut-parleur stéréo
d'autant plus que vous avez ici du Dolby
atmo c'est cool et en plus ici le son
est signé par Harman Kardon Harman
Kardon comme vous voulez autre truc à
savoir ici c'est que au niveau de la
performance on va avoir ce qui se fait
de mieux aujourd'hui c'est à dire un
snack dragon 8 plus gene one c'est celui
qui est sorti il y a pas très longtemps
qui est gravé par TSMC en 4 nanomètres
ok je vous passe un petit peu le truc
vous allez avoir soit 8 soit 12 Go de
RAM c'est de la lpdr 5 donc une techno
qui est très rapide qui est cool vous
allez avoir 128 soit 256 Go de stockage
en ufs 3.1 c'est aussi vachement bien en
lecture et en écriture c'est ravit ça
ira bien donc une fois de plus Xiaomi
fait ce que c'est fait un Xiaomi c'est à
dire une fiche technique musclé ok autre
point qui est intéressant ici et qu'on
vient retrouver dans ce smartphone c'est
une batterie de 5000 milliards une
grosse batterie de 5000 ma surtout de la
recharge rapide 120 watts 120 watts
c'est ce qu'on avait déjà l'année
dernière dans le Xiaomi on sait on
s'était pro on se tait je crois qu'on
avait eu vous le charger à 100% en 19
minutes donc ça c'est vachement cool et
le bloc de charge est inclus dans votre
boîte yes donc le truc qui est assez
vertueux ici c'est que comme on est ici
sur de la molette les pixel noir sont
des pixel éteint comme on a ici le
processeur de dernière génération de
Qualcomm le SAD dragon 8 plus genone et
bien il va être moins énergivore et donc
permettre de gagner en autonomie comme
vous avez une très grosse batterie de
5000 milliards vous allez l'emmener un
peu partout avec vous alors la
problématique de la batterie 5000
milliamper c'est que c'est un petit peu
lourd c'est pourquoi le smartphone qui
fait plus de 200 g ça je vous dis tout à
l'heure et comme vous avez pas vous
prendre la tronche vous le prenez vous
le rechargez vous êtes reparti donc la
question de l'autonomie et que ce
smartphone elle va disparaître donc ça
c'est sûr et ça c'est rassurant toute la
partie logiciel on est sur mewhite 13
basé sur un Android 12 alors bon je vous
passe très rapidement le truc je sais
pas si vous connaissez le White 13 on
est déjà parlé ça fonctionne bien c'est
très lisible au niveau des menus on s'y
repère très très facilement je vous l'ai
dit une fois de plus dans l'écran vous
venez là vous avez un thème sombre vous
avez un thème clair ok ça marche vous
avez votre schéma de couleur pour venir
moduler si vous le souhaitez passer en
saturé color original et compagnie ok
bon voilà à vous de voir vraiment ce qui
va vous botter ce qui va vous intéresser
ici mais ça ira très bien votre
fréquence actualisation pourrait venir
comme ça mettre en automatique ou alors
vous choisissez regardez vous choisissez
du 60 air toucher du 120 Hertz comme
vous voulez je vous conseille de vous
mettre ici en automatique comme ça c'est
lui qui va faire le taf directement bref
l'expérience logiciel est cool elle est
complète elle marche bien les signer
Xiaomi mais là où ce smartphone est
intéressant c'est justement sur la
partie photo alors on n'est pas ici sur
un Xiaomi 13 on n'est pas sur le plus
haut de gamme de Xiaomi on est sur un
milieu de gamme plus on est sur du haut
de gamme mais on n'est pas sur de
l'ultra haut de gamme ce qui fait que
Xiaomi fait des choix ils vous ont mis
un très gros capteur de 200 mégapixels
c'est un capteur de Samsung ici on va
pouvoir faire un truc qui est
intéressant c'est le fait de regrouper
16 pixels en un seul même et gros pixel
qui va capter plus de lumière et ça pour
la photo de nuit alors je vais vous
montrer je te fais quelques photos on va
se regarder les premiers résultats dans
quelques instants avant de vous donner
un résultat définitif quelques jours ici
on ouvre à F 1.69 et vous avez une
stabilisation optique autant vous dire
que ce capteur principal de 200
mégapixels franchement il est plutôt pas
dégueu fatalement il a fallu faire des
choix vous allez avoir un capteur
secondaire de 8 mégapixels pour l'ultra
grand-angle et un capteur de 2
mégapixels pour la macro bon ici on
s'attendra pas avoir des merveilles une
fois de plus on va regarder les
résultats dans quelques instants et à
l'avant vous avez une caméra selfie de
20 mégapixels ouvrez 2.4 vous pouvez
venir faire de la vidéo jusqu'en 8k 8k à
24 images par seconde oui vous avez un
processeur performant puissant qui vous
permet de le faire faut-il pour autant
bien filmer 8k je ne suis pas convaincu
mais on regardera ça dans quelques jours
lors du test alors je vous montre les
premières photos ici c'est dans un cadre
qui est juste splendide en Sicile il
fait beau il fait chaud le premier truc
que j'ai tendance un petit peu remarquer
c'est c'est signé Xiaomi aussi c'est que
c'est un peu saturé un peu sur saturé
c'est une signature les couleurs sont
pétantes voyez sont un peu vivides elles
vous claque à la gueule il y a un côté
flatteur ça marche on aime on n'aime pas
d'ailleurs du poste que vous en pensez
en bas dans les commentaires c'est votre
caméra principale ici on n'est pas en
mode 200 mégapixels je vais vous montrer
ce que ça raconte dans quelques instants
en mode 200 mégapixels on passe sur
l'ultra grand angle alors pas 20 ans il
y a une petite différence de
colorimétrie vous allez voir que les
Bleus sont un peu plus bleus c'est un
peu plus soutenu vous le verrez ici
également au niveau de la mer bon ça je
vous laisserai regarder on peut venir
zoomer un petit peu on se rapproche on
se rapproche bon ok je continue un peu
la balade comme ça vous voyez la
différence de colorimétrie ici entre le
grand-angle et l'ultra grand-angle
pareil ici vous voyez le truc que j'aime
bien je trouve que les photos sur ce
capteur de 200 mégapixels marche bien
voilà ultra grand-angle je me rapproche
je peux le dire vous-même un petit peu
si je vais au fond alors la caméra de
selfie bon c'est un peu en dessous je
trouve qu'il y a un côté un petit peu le
latin de peau qui est pas très joli quoi
voyez c'est ça me fait une espèce de
teinte qui est pas super belle et
lorsque je mets à contre-jour c'est
pareil ça fonctionne pas des masses des
masses ça va peut-être un peu la limite
du truc on arrive la nuit ça fonctionne
bien le 16 pixels en un fonctionne bien
et ça vous permet d'avoir des photos qui
sont très jolies de nuit regardez il a
tous les contours des lumières sont bien
maîtrisées tout ressort bien rien n'est
surexposé rien n'est cramé on a bien le
soleil couchant tout au fond en tout cas
ce qu'il en reste on voit bien le
mouvement des vagues de ce côté là je
trouve ça très sympa là histoire
quelques petits plats directement
siciliens alors ça c'est une pizza si
vous ne le savez pas c'est ça je ne
connaissais pas c'est juste magnifique
autre photo on revient à Paris le temps
est un petit peu moins sympathique ce
qu'on peut voir c'est la différence de
colorimétrie entre le grand angle et
l'ultra grand-angle après on peut venir
zoomer un petit peu regardez un truc qui
sont quand même très sympa ça marche
bien on passe sur du dragon angle petite
différence au niveau du verre et au
niveau du bleu et là je vous montre
rapidement aussi quelques photos que tu
as pris avec le capteur de 200
mégapixels donc ça c'est du 200
mégapixels c'est du 200 mégapixels c'est
du 200 mégapixels c'est du 200
mégapixels alors le truc qui est
intéressant c'est regarder je peux venir
zoomer dans l'image j'ai pas de
dégradation ou de perte de qualité je
peux venir chercher faut pas venir
chercher trop trop près parce qu'il y a
un moment où fatalement ça marchera plus
sans doutera vous voyez mais je pars
quand même de là et on peut quand même
venir regrouper venir zoomer ici grâce à
cette photo 200 mégapixels regardez la
d'un point de vue soft ce qu'on va avoir
donc le HDR hop là qu'il faut venir
activer ici ou désactive le HDA pour
venir zoomer sur X 2 max 2 x 6 c'est
marrant ça voyez parce que si j'en mets
le HDR tac on y va zoomer c'est comme ça
et pas autrement j'ai de l'autre côté ma
caméra de selfie avec le HDR que
j'active aussi que je désactive ça va
être mieux avec quand même sur caméra de
selfie un peu mieux sinon que vous
montrez ici document pro ok classique
vidéo photo alors photo je suis en fois
un fois 06 x 0,6 il est pas stabilisé le
poison il est stabilisément on le voit
regarder sa bouche pas que c'est tout
avec moi qui bouge énormément on voit
que ça bouge pas donc ça c'est bien le X
2 on stabiliser également c'est pas mal
ça doit être la même optique x 5 x 10
c'est le max après ça sert à rien
d'aller jusqu'à X et puis ensuite on a
un mode portrait en mode nuit et un mode
plus ici avec quelques éléments qu'on
peut venir mettre ici voilà comme ça au
moins vous voyez la base je vois
quelques premières images la tournée
avec le 12 et pro alors je fais gaffe
parce qu'il est pas encore sorti une
histoire de commencer à vous montrer et
bien on peut venir zoomer doucement
normalement là comme ça doucement
doucement doucement dans l'image jusqu'à
un fois 6 c'est hop jusqu'à un fois 1,6
la regarder shooter là-haut certes pas
trop mal bosser quand même au niveau de
la vidéo ça va être assez stabilisé
comme ça vous faites voir le temps est
très dégueulasse aujourd'hui donc bon ça
a l'air pas mal caméra de selfie bon bah
voilà pas de secret normalement les
caméras de Sophie sont un peu moins ça
aussi
c'est un smartphone qui a une double sim
du wifi 6 et du NFC pour le paiement des
matérialisé le Xiaomi 12 t Pro est
disponible au tarif de 799 euros et
d'ailleurs du 4 au 13 octobre une
tablette redmi pad d'une valeur de 299 €
est offerte pour l'achat d'un smartphone
de la série 12 T et si ce produit vous
intéresse vous pouvez le commander dès
maintenant je vous mets le lien une fois
de plus en bas dans la description alors
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez de ce
smartphone est-ce que vous avez des
choses en particulier que vous voulez
que j'aille voir des tests en
particulier des fonctionnalités que vous
avez envie que je regarde dites le moi
en bas dans les commentaires j'ai acheté
un coup d'oeil et j'ai regardé tout ça
pour ma vidéo test qui arrivera d'ici
quelques jours donc marquez moi ça en
bas dans les commentaires et puis
rendez-vous dans quelques jours pour la
vidéo test complète voilà bisous Ciao
[Musique]